selbst der regen dann apotheke schnee
dann eisregen dazu dass gefahren durch
die lust haben die bayern nicht mehr von
ladislao prozent hinaus gehalten und
sind geknickt bzw in brüssel waren die
dann in unsere klamm kreuz und quer in
die schlucht von sind
die bevölkerung sehr glücklich das
bundesheer häusern dass es weitergeht
wir wissen nicht wie man das sonst eher
waren werden dass man dass die schlucht
wieder freigelegt hätten
die heiligen geist kam ist absolut
verlass
das problem sind die steilen wände durch
den schnee drucks in die bäume alle mit
den baumwipfeln hinunter in das bachbett
gefallen und liegen jetzt so dass es
eine absolute verletzungsgefahr besteht
wir sind insgesamt mit 43 mann im
einsatz davon sind 29 rekruten im
zweiten ausbildungsjahr
mit kettensägen und vielen hilfskräften
ziehen wir uns schneiden wir die bäume
und die wurzelstöcke aus der klamm
hinaus mit dem keine verstopfungen
weiterhin bleiben das jetzt mein zweites
monat grundausbildung ist vorbei und
jetzt zum einsatz gekommen